hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of this year's Norway chess it is
Hikaru Nakamura vs Fabiano Corona and
like we've mentioned in the previous
video uh Hikaru is the only one who can
win the tournament aside from Fabi Fabi
is leading the tournament but if he car
wins in classical uh he will uh reach uh
uh uh that first place he will get three
points for a winning classical and uh or
over take five these were sorry these
were the standings after round eight so
Fabiano with 16 Fabi uh hika with 13 and
a half and should hikar win he will have
16 and a half the Fabi 16 and although
bookish is very close uh he cannot um
win the tournament even even if he wins
his classical game uh that means Fabi
has to lose but if Fabi loses that means
Hikaru has won and then of course again
Hikaru wins the tournament so that's the
problem for Lucas but uh it's Hikaru and
Fabi they are battling it up for first
place let's see what happened as the
opening choice is uh quite admirable for
uh for them and for us the viewers so
here Pawn to E4 we have Pawn to E5
Knight to F3 Knight to C6 and now Bishop
to C4 the Italian game is on the board
uh Knight to F6 the two nice defense and
of course how do we deal with this well
either D3 or Knight to G5 the Knight
attack is what Hikaru goes for and uh
well we we couldn't ask for a better
opening for the final game that could
decide the tournament and here uh you
have two options you have to go for D5
which is the move that of it's the
serious attempt or you go for the
Traxler attack which uh you will see in
Wood you will see it in Blitz you might
even see it somewhere in Rapid but um
you're not gonna see it in in a serious
classical game so here Pawn to D5 with e
Captain D5 Knights the A5 and Bishop to
B5 with check uh all the same moves as
they were played 150 years ago Pawn to
C6 captures captures and now you can
bring the bishop all the way to E2 you
can play Queen to F3 this is also uh
very popular uh you can
um well there are different ways of
playing this but Bishop to D3 although
not as popular as Bishop to E2 and queen
to F3 uh you know is uh slowly but
surely becoming a favorite of many top
Grand Masters so here uh of course you
are stopping the usual H6 and uh and
Ponte E4 so here black has to figure out
a different way to treat this Knight the
D5 is the main idea now the queen
attacks the Knight Knight back to F3
attacks the E5 Pawn in the bishop to D6
just defending that E5 Pawn we have
castles and now a knight to F4 putting
pressure on the bishop here and just
Knight the C3 Hikaru allows Fabi to mess
up his Pawn structure but that's all
planned Knight captures on D3 C captures
and now uh for uh queen king side
castles and here uh Knight the E4 is the
usual move we have Pawn to B3 by Hikaru
now seeing that he's ready to Defiance
of his dark Square Bishop Rook to E8 and
now Rook the E1 we have found the C5
preparing The Thinker to this bishop to
claim this guy Channel or in some lines
maybe even the bishop can count the A6
to put more pressure on D3 by the bishop
and the queen so Bishop to A3 and now
Knight back to C6 we have Knight the E4
uh and uh there is a game where Bishop
to G4 was played Just spinning that
Knight but here we have Bishop back to
f8 by Fabi and it is now as of move 16
that we have a completely new game
uh so interestingly here a rook the C1
Rook to C1 is played and already in this
move uh Fabi completely uh misses uh how
how this should be played now there are
uh various ways you could treat this
position uh the top moves are some like
Knight to B4 which you should play F6
also could work in this position but
what you cannot do is play Queen
captures on D3 I'm just gonna show it
real quickly uh because after Bishop
captures on C5 okay you can trade right
away better maybe it's Bishop to F5 and
after Knight to G3 attacking the bishop
here Rook a to C8 Bishop captures an f8
King captures and now Rook to C3 you
chase away the queen and after the queen
moves you will play Rook captures on C6
and here white simply okay this is only
one of the possible lines is about the
white will will definitely have an edge
you can't capture with the queen because
the bishop hangs and if you capture with
the Rook white will win back the
exchange with Knight captures on E5
let's say captures captures and the
white always enjoys those um two extra
pawns so that's the only one problem
another thing okay Knights the B4 is a
possibility instead of Queen captures on
D3 and it is objectively best for black
but then uh for example bash of captures
Pawn captures and queen to C2 uh already
it's uh not uh uh well it's it's a
completely different game it's a bishop
to G4 and black can be very very happy
uh but instead after Rook to C1 five we
played Pawn to F5 and already this could
be considered the losing move for Fabi
uh because the positions that will now
happen well Knight captures in C5 was
played uh just winning another pawn and
it's okay okay in the two nice defense
when you go for this uh you will often
sacrifice a pawn you will sacrifice upon
definitely and then whether or not you
will sacrifice second one uh depends but
here it is incredibly difficult to hold
it for Fabi uh Queen to D5 was played
and now Hikaru plays Queen to C2 here I
actually checked at the depth uh 16 with
with a neural network and in the
stockfish 16 uh Here pawn to B4 is the
best move and it is a winning idea as it
is in most possessions and I can even
show you what what they come up with
like Ponte A6 Queen to A4 and now Bishop
to E6 but now Knights the G5 pressuring
the bishop twice Bishop back to C8 and
not Knight C the E4 and now uh I mean a
beautiful stuff here uh by our good
friends the neural networks and you
cannot capture if you capture then you
undouble your pawns attack the queen and
once the queen moves you play Pawn to D4
and it looks silly I mean you're
sacrificed upon but what about the
Knight here and why you play D4 why not
just capture here point is that after
Queen to F6 now you're attacking this
Knight there's Queen B3 check and now
yeah there's a problem if you if you
move the king then of course Knight to
F7 check so you have to play Bishop T6
Knight captures and E6 Queen captures
and now you even trade the captors
captures and pawn to D5 this is how you
uh win it Rook to G 6 for example in our
Rook captures and C6 and again white has
too much material however Hikaru played
Queen to C2 which is also a very fine
move uh and uh Fabi went to Rook to B8
and this uh okay maybe Pawn to F5 is not
the losing move but Rook to B8 is maybe
Rook to d8 should still
uh sorry Rook to be it should be played
Rook the d8 the move that Fabi played uh
is the losing move here uh and now we
have Queen to C4 that Hikaru immediately
offers a queen trade and uh it's um it
cannot be avoided the king and queen are
on the same diagonal uh Queen to C3 also
very strong but uh Hikaru uh uh the
things that this is this is quite enough
so Queen captures on C4 and now Rook
captures on C4 you would of course like
to undouble your pawns but then you lose
control over the E4 square and then E4
is just super annoying if Knight the G5
then h69 to H3 uh Rook capture Sunday to
end so on black is very much back in the
game but here Rook captures and C4 was
played and now Rook to D5 we have Rook e
to C1 doubling up on the C file and the
bishop to D6 and here uh okay the
situation of the clock is Fabi has some
45 minutes Hikaru a full hour uh this
should back to B2 putting more pressure
on that E5 Pawn uh and Knight the E7 we
have Rook for to C2 and now Rook the B8
finally Fabi brings this Rook into the
game uh the problem is if you consider
trading here a little bit let's say real
captures real captures a new capture on
D3 uh then wrote captures on E5 and of
course white is completely winning here
so I have to work for the C2 we have
rooked the B8 by Fabi and now Pawn to D4
now beautifully done by Hikaru the point
is that E4 does not work you're gonna
play Knights the E5 and the black's
position is just really bad there's a
hardly a move you can make here and even
if you try to eliminate some of the
pieces it captures captures Knight to G6
to put pressure on the E5 Pawn Knight
captures an E4 and again now the the
bishop and see it is hanging and if you
don't play Knight to G6 what what are
you playing the Knight fully controls
the bush of The Rook has the moves the
Knight cannot move because of the uh the
threat that we've just discussed it's uh
it's a really bad position for black
so instead Hikaru plays e Captain D4
Knight captures on D4 and now Pawn to A5
and okay Hikaru uh Fabi finds um some
active moves here Knight to F3 and pawn
to H6 stopping Knight to G5 and now
Knight the A4 now here uh D4 is also a
very nice idea but Hikaru has a
different plan Knight to A4 he wants to
bring the Rook uh up the board and now
of course uh the Knight still cannot
move because of real characters on C8 uh
so Bishop to A6 getting rid of that and
now Knight back to C3 Rook to C5 and now
Bishop to A3 forcing some trades here as
Hikaru is up two pawns any peace trade
uh goes a long way for him so Rook to C6
uh Bishop captures The Rook captures and
now Knights the A4 with knights the D5
uh and Rook to C6 just forcing more
trades uh Rook captures on C6 maybe Rook
b38 is a little bit better but it's
already hard to say at this point the
Rook captures Rook captures uh and now
Knights the B4 putting brush
but now Rook to D6 and here comes the
bishop to B7 you cannot capture on A2 of
course as the bishop on A6 would hang so
Bishop B7 and now Knight back to C3 and
now the problem is yes you're up to
pawns but that's not the worst of your
problems black has no uh no reasonable
plan here you cannot uh capturinate you
you cannot dislodge the Knight The Rook
cannot attack it of course the bishop
cannot attack these lights or version of
the night is on a dark Square uh you
cannot bring the Rook for example to e
to this covered by the Knight E1 is
covered by the Knight so even if you
even if you had like five moves in a row
you have no idea what you would play
okay obviously you could capture and
move the bishop back but you know you
know what I mean so Rook to E8 and now
Pawn to H for creating some breathing
room for the king of course you don't
want to move the Knight and get some
sort of a back rank mate and now Pawn to
F4 you could also capture here but
captures captures okay or maybe ruins
Fabi spawn structure a little bit but
you can't trade pieces you're down too
much uh too many pawns so instead of
Pawn to F4 a weird move but what you're
gonna do at least you keep that jeep on
it Bay uh Rook to D4 now attacks the F4
pawn and The Rook to f8 Fabi defends it
hopes that he can maybe hold this with
knights the E5 Rook the E8 and now
Knight to C4 remember Fabi only needs a
rod to win the tournament uh Pawn to F3
and now G captures an F3 Bishop captures
and King the H2 we have knighted the C2
and now Rook to D3 putting pressure on
the bishop Bishop back all the way to A8
and now King to G3 uh just uh
solidifying and not allowing um
not far be any control play King to H7
Knight to E3 and now Knight back to B4
attacks The Rock but just to Rook to D6
not a problem and you you know that it's
going to be very safe there the Knight
needs four moves to reach that Rook uh
Knight to C6 and now Knight C to D5 we
have Rook to f8 and now uh Knight's the
C7 attacking the bishop you don't want
this knife to move and then some sort of
a rook to F3 check to happen so you uh
pressure the bishop with Bishop to B7
and down Knight the East expressuring
the rook and f8 Rook to F7 and now Pawn
to F4 so you no longer have to worry
about the Rook coming to F3 Bishop to A8
and now just Pawn to H5 uh paralyzing
black
even more uh Rook to A7 and here we have
Pawn to A3 and the situation on the
clock is uh Hikaru 33 minutes and Fabi
30 seconds on the clock with King the G8
uh Now Pawn to F5 uh he corresponds and
pieces uh can just freely March forward
there is nothing Fabi can do here Rook
is 7 and now King to F4 we have rooked
the A7 and now Pawn to D4 Andy was in
this position and move 55 uh that Hikaru
Nakamura or rather Fabiano caruana
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here he's out of active
moves but mostly he is just down uh too
much on time he had five seconds on the
clock and okay yes there is increment
but
and there's no move that you can make it
doesn't really matter the past d-pawn
will start marching forward you can
create a past spawn with a move like
Pawn to B4 I mean you you can do
whatever you want here you can even
sacrifice on F6 to put the King on F5
and G6 then start winning pawns even
more maybe even Checkmate the black king
really the sky is the limit in this
position of course Fabi knows this and
that's why he resigned and I haven't um
I haven't prepared for the uh video the
uh the new live ratings I will just
check it real quickly uh I don't wanna
uh misinform you guys but yeah of course
Hikaru is now the world number two in
classical he's up by 12 points uh and uh
Fabi world number three plus uh on plus
eight of course rule number four Dean
Lillian and world number five uh yeah an
apology world number six eleven is a
future and so on and so on I will make
at least one more video from the final
round and then we are going to enjoy the
live ratings uh in its uh in their
entirety uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it um a very
interesting opening Choice by Hikaru uh
he went for this uh Knights the G5 line
of course we all love to see the Knight
attack it is uh I mean it is why why we
love chess it is why we started playing
chess basically and we love it when
someone plays it in the absolute top
level World number two versus World
number three uh it does not get any
better than uh than this so yeah I
really enjoyed this uh Fabi I played it
well up until the point that we've
mentioned that okay everything up until
this point was known but then this F5
move uh followed by this Rook the d8
move and from that it was just the point
of no return
um it was just the the position was was
as such and there was no going back so
yeah really a beautiful beautiful uh
positional Master music by Hikaru taking
down a Fabiana corwan I hope you guys
enjoyed that I would like to thank David
Kimura and David gaspari and Ricky
Johnson faded Sonic and hydraga for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage or
rather we'll check out a few more games
from this tournament and then I'm uh of
course waiting for for the next one and
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions while I'm preparing the next
big Saga and yes I am still preparing it
uh so thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day